[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذا اللقاء الخاص
الذي نلتقي فيه الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي الذي تخوض بلاده حربا وصفت
بالاشرس والاعنف والاخطر بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه نحاوره حول هذه الحرب
وتداعياتها العسكريه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه والانسانيه فاهلا بكم الى هذا
الحوار اهلا بك السيد الرئيس قسمين
سيدي الرئيس هل كان من الممكن بالنسبه لكم
تجنب هذه الحرب خاصه انه كان هناك
اتفاقيات مسبقه الحديث عن النسخه الاولى
والثانيه من الذي خلق هذه الاتفاقيات
ولماذا لم يتم تنفيذها
هل سيكون افضل ان حدثتك بالروسيه يمكنك
التحدث بالاوكرانيه فانا افهمها جيدا
طبعا حكومتنا لم توقع على اتفاقيه منسك
انا لم اوقعها كرئيس لقد وقعوها قبلي انها
الحقيقه لكن بالطبع كان هناك قرار من
الدوله وعلينا الامتثال له هناك قوه
الكلمه قوه الدوله الكلمه التي يعطيها
الرئيس مهما كان سابقا حاضرا الدوله تتبع
مسارا معينه
اتفاقيات في رايي كانت عمليه اتفاقيه منسك
نفسها ليست عمليه انهاء الحرب الجميع
بحاجه الى فهم هذا لقد كانت عمليه تحديد
المكان الذي توقفت فيه روسيا احتلت شبه
جزيره القرم وضمتها دون قتال للاسف للاسف
لم تقاتل اوكرانيا من اجل القرن استطاعت
ام لم تستطع فلندعي الحكم للاجيال القادمه
على اي حال استولت روسيا عن القرن بعد ذلك
استولت على جزء من دومباس بدات الحرب وبدا
الموت وفي تلك اللحظه تعرفون وقعت
المجموعه الرباعيه المكونه من فرنسا
والمانيا وروسيا واوكرانيا اتفاقيه منسك
لوضع خطه الاجراءات لانهاء الحرب رغم انه
لم يطلق عليها احد في ذلك الوقت حربا حسب
علمكم
لكن هذا ليس مفهوما بالنسبه اليه ماذا كان
ذلك قتل الناس وتم احتلال الاراضي وكانت
هناك قطعه من الورق لا يمكن تسميتها
بطريقه اخرى لان الاشخاص الذين وقعوا
عليها لم يكونوا ينوونه في اي شيء كانت
روسيا بحاجه فقط الى التوقف وتجميد الصراع
فعلت الشيء نفسه في جورجيا وفعلت الشيء
نفسه في مولدوفا وفعلت الشيء نفسه في
نهايه المطاف في سوريا وبلدان اخرى قلت
انك من السودان روسيا في كل مكان توجد فيه
تخلق صراعات مجمده في كل مكان
ما هو الصراع المجمد انها مساله وقت قبل
ان تعود روسيا للاحتلال مره اخرى الهدف لم
يتغير احتلال اوكرانيا بالكامل نظرا الى
انك عشت في اوكرانيا وتعلم انني شخص مسالم
تماما وانا جميع الاوكرانيين امه مسالمه
تماما طبعا حتى يبدا بقتلنا عندها اعذرني
علينا حمايه انفسنا
وعائلاتنا واعتقد اننا نفعل ذلك نحن نفعل
ذلك بالكرامه وبافضل طريقه ممكنه نحن
انفسنا مع الحلفاء ام وحدنا هذا امر اخر
لكن الاهم انه يجب ان نحمي بلدنا واطفالنا
في اتفاقيه ميسك لاكن صادقه لم احترم هذه
القطعه من الورق واتعامل معها على هذا
النحو لان كل شيء كتب فيها كتب بطريقه
تجعلنا نتنازل عن
ولكن مع ذلك كانت منبره انت قلت بشكل صحيح
يمكن للناس ان يجتمعوا ويتحدثوا دبلوماسيه
وكانت هذه رغبه ورغبه الناس في اوكرانيا
ايجاد الحوار بهذه الطريقه ايجاد الصيغه
الصيغه التي تمنع لا قدر الله الحرب
الواسعه النطاق وحتى نتمكن من انهاء
احتلال اراضينا وشعبنا اهم شيء هو الناس
الذين كانوا في هذه الاراضي المحتله ان
اتصلت التقينا في صيغه في صيغه هناك
اتفاقيات مثبته كانت هذه اتفاقياتنا في
وجود فرنسا والمانيا كانت هناك اتفاقيات
بيني رئيس اوكرانيا وبوتين رئيس روسيا
اتفاقيه واضحه جدا باننا سنوقف اطلاق
النار وان نصنع ممرا انسانيا لتبادل كل
الاسرى مقابل كل الاسرى لقد اتفقنا اتفقنا
وبصراحه لم يكن احد يريد تنفيذ اي شيء
كنت ارى ذلك منذ البدايه في البدايه اعدنا
100 شخص في البدايه كان هناك وقف لاطلاق
النار ثم عاد كل شيء مره اخرى الى ما كان
عليه كان هناك قصف واستفزازات انا اردت ان
اوقفها طلبت مكالمه طلبت ان نلتقي اردت
حقا ان نلتقي في اجتماع في صيغه ثم اقترحت
اللقاء باي صيغه قلت انني مستعد للقاء
بوتين في اي مكان لكن يجب وقف اطلاق النار
لانه سيؤدي الى حرب شامله هذا يمكن ان
يؤدي الى ذلك الامر الذي لا يرغب فيه احد
وطبعا كنا لا نصدق انه سيذهب بمعنى ان
بوتين سيشن الحرب رغم اننا فهمنا ان هذا
كان هدفه لكني اعتقدت ان العالم سيوقف هذا
الانسان بعد لقائنا في نورماندي لم وجبنا
احد لمده عامين لم يرغب احد بالحديث معنا
عبر الهاتف لم يكن هناك نقاش موضوعي ثم
بدات الحرب الواسعه النطاق الغزو الواسع
النطاق مع التعذيب والاغتصاب وكل هذه
عواقب حرب الفتح هذه هي حقيقه اتفاقيات
منسك لم ترغب روسيا ابدا في فعل اي شيء
فقد ارادت دائما ان تفعل اوكرانيا شيئا ما
وليس فقط اوكرانيا ارادت روسيا ان يفعل
الجميع واي سيطرهم على كل شيء حتى عندما
بدا الغزو الواسع النطاق تذكر شروطهم
ولغتهم التي تحدثوها تسليم مصالحنا وارضنا
والس الكامله على دولتنا هذا هو الارهاب
انه وجه الارهاب الحديث
الاتحاد الروسي يقول انكم اتيتم بناته الى
حدودهم وهذا مهدد لعبنهم القومي كيف تردون
على ذلك
بيني وبينك هذا منذ زمن طويل لا اجيب
الاتحاد الروسي على اي شيء ساجيبكم انتم
اولا اوكرانيا ليست عضوا في النيتو ثانيا
لا نحتاج فقط الى موافقه اوكرانيا
للانضمام الى التحالف من الضروري ان يوافق
جميع الحلفاء على ان تكون اوكرانيا جزءا
من النيتو ثالثا انتبهوا لما يمثله حلف
النيتو بنسبه الى روسيا اعتقد ان هذا مجرد
عذر خلال الحرب الشامله اصبحت فنلندا عضوا
في النيتو وقالت روسيا اذا النيتو لا يكون
ابدا على الحدود مع روسيا
تفضل ها هي دوله اخرى عضو في النيتو على
الحدود مع روسيا هذا ليس هجوم النيتو يرى
الجميع ما تستطيع روسيا فعله ويريد الجميع
حمايه انفسهم منه اليوم الزيت ليس ذلك
الحلف لا يقود اي هجوم لا ارى ان دول
النيت تشن الان اي نوع من الحرب لا ارى
وجود النيت داخل الحدود الروسيه لا ارى اي
جندي من النيتو يقتل الروس في اراضي روسيا
او في اي مكان اخر لا ارى جنود النيتو
يدخلون ويغتصبون مع الاعتذار بنات
العائلات الروسيه اين هذا لا يوجد مثل هذا
الشيء اما عندنا اتى الجندي الروسي وفعل
كل هذا على اراضينا يقلق الفنلنديون مثل
الناس العاديين الطبيعيين تماما وقد فهموا
كل شيء لو لم تهاجمنا روسيا لمنضمت ابدا
في لندن الى حلف الناتو لكن جميع الدول
التي تقع الان اما على الحدود مع روسيا او
لديها اي علاقات اقتصاديه وكان الاقتصاد
الروسي يؤثر عليهم الجميع يريد الاستقلال
عن روسيا استقلال الطاقه والاستقلال
الاقتصاديه والزراعي يريد الجميع
الاستقلال راوا كيف اغلقوا ممرات الخبز
القادم من اوكرانيا لقد ادركوا انهم سيلون
اذرعهم غائبا وفي كل مكان فقط لتحقيق
نتائجهم الان كل هذه الدول تريد الانضمام
الى النيتو لحمايه انفسها نحن نحمي انفسنا
بدون الناتو على ارضنا نحن لم ندخل موسكو
بالدبابات كما دخلوا هم عاصمتنا ولم نسرق
احدا ولم نقتل احدا ولم نسرق مراحيض هذا
شيء مضحك ان روسيا في حاله حرب عنيت على
اراضي اوكرانيا روسيا في حاله حرب مع
اوكرانيا ولكنها غير قادره على القتال
بالشرف تقول بالفعل انها في حال حرب مع
النيتو لانه من العار الاعتراف بان بلد
اكبر من اوكرانيا باربعين مره غير قادر
على هزيمتنا هذا هو الحال انهم يواصلون
الانخراط في الروايات نفسها لسكانهم داخل
بلدهم بان العالم كله في حاله حرب مع
روسيا اذا كان العالم كله في حال حرب مع
روسيا لكان العالم كله بالفعل الان على
اراضي روسيا منذ وقت طويل لا احد يقاتلهم
مجدفنه
ايضا هناك راي يقول ان الناتو والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه دفعت بكم دفعا الى هذه
الحرب لاستنزاف روسيا كيف تردون على ذلك
عندما اصبحت رئيسا وعندما بدا الحديث عن
ذلك اننا ندفع الى هذه الحرب ظللت افكر
متى يتصل باحد ما على الاقل ويقول لي هيا
تقدم على العكس من ذلك كان العالم كله
يبحث عن طريقه حتى لا تبدا حرب شامله لا
سمح الله لان العالم كله بصراحه عاش لفتره
طويله جدا في هذه الروايه انه لا ينبغي ان
تغضب روسيا فعلى العكس تماما كان العالم
كله خائفا من انه لا سمح الله اذا اغضبت
الروس تكون هناك حرب نوويه العالم كله
يريد ان يعيش بدون حرب العالم العربي ليس
استثناء نحن نعلم متى يقوم الطغاه تحت
ستار الخلاص الوطني المفترض بالاستيلاء
على البلدان الاخرى وتدميرها الم يكن
الامر كذلك مع الكويت هل استولى صدام حسين
مختبئا وراء شيء ما هناك على البلاد
ودمرها في الحقيقه كان مجرد خاسر هذا كل
شيء تماما مثل بوت من هو الخاسر من لم يقم
باي اصلاحات اقتصاديه دوله غنيه بالموارد
المعدنيه وكل هذا ببساطه مسروق لكن من
الضروري لهم الحفاظ على هذه الدرجه
باستمرار انه وحده القادر على الحفاظ على
تماسك الاراضي الروسيه فقط هو القادر على
تحسين رفاهيه سكانه ولكن كيف يكون ذلك
ممكنا هذا ما فعله الطغاه هذه هي الطريقه
التي استخدمها هتلر لتجنب الانهيار
الاقتصادي الامر ذاته هذا هو العثور على
بعض الشر المتخيل او العدو من الخارج
والقتال معه ومن خلال ذلك توطيد المجتمع
لقد وجد عدوا فينا وفي النيت من اجل تماسك
المجتمع ويقولون انه لا خيار امامه سوى
انقاذ بلاده والشعب الروسي باستثناء
الاستيلاء على اوكرانيا التي تدمر روسيا
اين ندمره بما دمرنا انه مستقلون في
الطاقه ومستقلون زراعيا ولديهم كل شيء
لديهم دوله غنيه وببساطه ليس لديهم ضمير
لا يوجد ضمير على الاطلاق وهم فاشيون
حقيقيون سياستهم الاعلاميه هي تماما سياسه
غوبلز يقولون انه لا يوجد سوى شعب عظيم
واحد هو الشعب الروسي كيف ذلك حسنا كيف
نعيش جميعا اذا علينا ان نعيش بطريقه ما
في سلام على هذا الكوكب هذا الكوكب ليس
روسيا الكوكب الارض تعتقد انه يطلق عليه
ذلك اذا كنا انا وانت نتحدث بالروسيه لذلك
وجدوا كل انواع الروايات كما يقولون هنا
في اوكرانيا ينتهكون اللغه الروسيه حتى
انك بدات تتحدث معي باللغه الروسيه اجيب
عليك باللغه الروسيه لا احد يعترض امر اخر
هو الا احد يريد التحدث بعد الان انها
حقيقه مطلقه لقد دمرها بنفسه
بعد مرور نحو عام وثلاثه اشهر على الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كيف ترى الاوضاع على
الارض في جميع المقاطعات وخاصه في
نحن نقاتل الحرب انا بالتاكيد لا استطيع
ان اصف الوضع بانه جيد لكننا نكافح نحن
اقوى مما كنا عليه قبل عام لقد حررنا بعض
اراضينا البلد متحد وعلى فكره البلد متحد
من اجل النصر نامل ونصدق انه بخطوات يوميه
نقترب من النصر وانا واثق من ذلك وهذا مهم
جدا هو دافعنا الرئيسي تحرير واستعاده
ارضنا الوصول الى حدودنا وتطوير بلادنا
نريد السلام ونريد نهايه الحرب نريدها
ونقاتل من اجلها اعطاء فرصه لتجميد النزاع
مرارا وتكرارا لمده عشر سنوات اخرى للحديث
عن شيء معهم كتفاقيه مسك الجديده او ايا
كان اسم ذلك الاستيلاء على المزيد من
اراضينا ما هو الصراع المجمد انت تفهمنا
حسنا يعني سياتي احد الى هنا لن تكون
اوكرانيا عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي ولن
تكون هناك استثمارات لماذا لانه هناك
بالفعل مثالان عندما كانت هناك حرب واسعه
نطاق على مدى 30 عاما كيف يمكن للمرء ان
يستثمر في مثل هذا البلد كيف يمكنك
استثمار المال لشخص ما في هذا البلد كيف
يمكنك اداره عمل تجاري مفتوح هنا انه امر
خطير بكل بساطه هذه مخاطر عاليه وهذا ما
تريده روسيا لا يمنح الاستقلال لاوكرانيا
لان اوكرانيا ستنطلق بالتاكيد ستتطور
اوكرانيا بسرعه كبيره حتى اثناء الحرب
نتطور بسرعه كبيره انهم خائفون جدا
سيفقد ما ذهب اليه بهذا العدوان سوف يفقد
ثقه شعبه في ان الدول المجاوره لروسيا هي
نفسها تماما او اسود سيرى الجميع كيف
تتطور دول خارج النفوذ الروسي وهم يحققون
النجاح ولا يمكنه ان يغفر لنفسه ولن يغفر
المجتمع اذا تطورت اوكرانيا سرعان ما تصبح
عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي وهلم جره هذا كل
شيء انه يقاتل من اجل حياته هذا ما يقاتل
من اجله اثناء قتاله في اوكرانيا يقاتل
بوتين فقط لانقاذ حياته انه لا يقاتل حتى
من اجل روسيا ولا من اجل لغته الروسيه انه
لا يقاتل من اجل ذلك
ليس من اجل الكنيسته انه يقاتل فقط من اجل
حياته
سيد الرئيس القتال العنيف يتركز الان في
بخموت الشرق البلاد وانتم ذكرتم اكثر من
مره ان الوضع هناك معقد للغايه هل انتم
متمسكون بالحفاظ على ضخموت مهما كانت
التكلفه ولماذا على الرغم من ان الشركاء
صرحوا بانهم نصحوكم بالانسحاب
انصحوا جميع القاده العسكريين الاذكياء
بتحمل المسؤوليه اولا عن اقوالهم وانصحوا
جميع الصحفيين الذين يدعمون مثل هذه
الروايات بتحمل المسؤوليه عن افعالهم لهذا
يجب معرفه طبيعه المكان والوضع انت تعرف
اين هذا وماذا هناك وكيف انا انصحهم ان
ياتوا لياروا ويفهموا ما يمكن ان يحدث ما
هي التهديدات انا اتشاور فقط مع جيشنا ومع
استخباراتنا هنا لدينا جميعا راي لا لب من
المستحيل التخلي عن ضخمه لان هذا سيزيد من
حجم الجبهه هو هذا سيعطي القوات الروسيه
والفاجنر المزيد من الفرص للاستيلاء على
المزيد من اراضينا اليوم باخمت التي تربط
مجموعه كبيره من الروس وفي الحقيقه حصن من
الناس الابطال المطلقين وكلهم يفهمون انهم
يؤدون اصعب مهمه تكتيكيه هذا راي جيشنا
واستخباراتنا وكل العسكريين الموجودين على
الكراس الدافئه في الدول الاخرى حفظهم
الله
ايضا سيد الرئيس ترددت انباء عن استعدادات
تقوم بها اوكرانيا لشد عمليه عسكريه مضاده
في الربيع هل ستمضي هذه العمليه كما هو
مخطط لها رغم العراقيل اللوجستيه والبشريه
كوندرنا
الهجوم المضاد سيحدث نحن نؤمن بنجاح هذا
الهجوم المضاد لكن من الصعب ان اقول شيئا
مقدما ويبدو لي انه غير عادل ان اتحدث عن
ذلك لان اولادنا وبناتنا يستعدون جيشنا
يستعد نحن نفعل كل شيء لتقويته هل هذا
يكفي اليوم لا ليس كافيه نحن لا نستعد فقط
لهجوم مضاد بل ما زلنا نقف ونمسك بالعدو
وهاتان مهمتان يصعب للغايه القيام بهما في
وقت واحد ومع ذلك سنستعد سننتظر لان بعض
المواعيد لا تتناسب مع توقعاتنا بخصوص
استيراد اسلحه معينه لكننا سننتظر سيكون
هناك بالتاكيد هجوم مضاد
الوثائق السريه للبنتاغون التي تسربت
مؤخرا تحدثت عن مشاكل لوجستيه تتعرض لها
القوات الاوكرانيه ما مدى دقه هذه
المعلومات هل تسريب هذه الوثائق سيؤدي الى
تغيير في الخطط العسكريه للقوات
الاوكرانيه على الارض هي تشيستنكر
لن اقول كيف تؤثر هذه الرسائل على خططنا
والهجوم المضاد وعدد من هذه الوثائق ما
يزال يراهن على هذه القصه يمكنك ان تشرح
لي صحفي انا مهتم برايك من يحتاج الى ذلك
من يحتاج الى هذه المعلومات من تساعد وبمن
تضر هذا يقود الى انه بالنسبه الينا في
الحاله الاولى او الثانيه لا يشكل فرق
الهجوم المضاد سيحدث
رغم المساعدات العسكريه التي تدفقت على
اوكرانيا الى ان السلطات الاوكرانيه تطالب
بالمزيد هل تتوقعون استمرار الدعم مهما
طالت هذه الحرب
يجب ان يفهم نحن ممتنون لحلفائنا لكنهم
يساعدون انفسهم ايضا حقيقه ان روسيا لن
تتوقف عند اوكرانيا وهذا امر جلي للجميع
اتضح هذا بعد ترهيبهم بالنووي وما الى ذلك
روسيا لن تتوقف في اوكرانيا او روسيا
ستتوقف على وجه التحديد عن طريق اوكرانيا
نحن نقدر الخيار الثاني لانه ليس لدينا
خيار لا نريد ان نكون ضحايا لكن ليس لدينا
خيار سنقاتل حتى النهايه ولذا فاننا نقدم
الخيار الثاني الحلفاء ادعمونا لانه اولا
قبل كل هذا ثمن شهيد بنسبه اليه لان روسيا
ستذهب ابعد من ذلك وستموت قواتكم وشعوبكم
وستقاتلون من اجل دوالكم لا يمكنكم خلاف
ذلك هذا ما اعتقده لذلك السؤال المطروح
ليس كم يمكنكم مساعدتنا انما كم يمكنهم
مساعده انفسهم هذا الامر الاول القصه
الثانيه لا اعتقد ان هذه الحرب ستكون
طويله لا اعتقد روسيا مستعده انا متاكد من
ان بوت مستعد لكن بوتين لا يقاتل وبوت لا
يموت
وساقا بوتين وذراعاه لا تقطع رغم انني
اعتقد انه يستحق ذلك والناس العاديون
يموتون وهم عاديون لكنهم حصلوا على صفه
القتله عندما اتوا الى اراضينا واطلقوا
النار على جيشنا وعلى المدنيين هذا كل شيء
فوت مستعد للاستمرار القتال فتره طويله
لست متاكدا من استعداد روسيا لكننا سنرى
يبدو وضعنا مختلفا بعض الشيء نحن جميعا
على استعداد للوقوف طالما كان ذلك ضروريه
وتاليا اعتقد اننا اقوى واعتقد اننا سنفوز
لكن بدون مساعده الحلفاء سيكون الامر صعب
بالنسبه الينا ومع ذلك يقولون ان هذا هو
الجيش الثاني في العالم وبالتالي ليس من
السهل علينا التعامل معه
كذلك سيدي الرئيس هناك انباع عن خلافات
بينكم وبين
حلفائكم الغربيين بشان تزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح ومواقيت ومواعيد وصول هذه الاسلحه
ما دقه ذلك وما هو مصدر هذه الخلافات تشد
اصبروا
الاسلحه تصل الينا ابطاء مما كنا نتوقع
الحلفاء يقررون اذا كان هذا السلاح قد يصل
اليوم او غدا في بعض الاحيان تكون هناك
بعض المشكلات اللوجستيه لكنني اعرف ان بعض
القاده قلقون وهم يفعلون كل شيء حتى ياتي
الدعم الينا بشكل اسرع كل يوم عندما
تتباطؤ الاسلحه يتباطؤ النصر الامر لا
يتعلق فقط بالاسلحه انه يتعلق بالكثير من
الاشياء انهم جميعا يفهمون اننا نفقد
اشخاص وهذا ثمن باهظ
وسط المعارك العنيفه ظهرت اتهامات بالفساد
هزت سوره الحكومه الاوكرانيه وتمت اقاله
عدد كبير من المسؤولين الى اين وصلت
التحقيقات في قضايا الفساد وكيف اثرت على
الدعم المادي الذي تتلقاه اوكرانيا من
الدول الغربيه وما هي الاجراءات التي تم
اتخاذها لمكافحه الفساد وانهاء هذه
الظاهره
خلال الحرب الكل يركز على الحرب وهذا هو
الشيء الاكثر اهميه رغم حقيقه ان بلدنا
بلد الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه المناسبه
والاصلاحات لمكافحه الفساد يجب ان لا ننسى
انه يجب اتخاذ كل هذه الخطوات لكن من
الصعب اتخاذها اثناء الحرب اخبرني الكثير
من القاده انهم لا يفهمون كيف يمكننا فعل
اي شيء اخر غير الحرب نحاول جاهدين نحن
دوله كبيره من حيث الحجم 40 مليون نسمه
هناك حاله فساد نحاربها وانا فخور بالسرعه
التي نتخلص بها من مثل هذه الحاله ومع ذلك
كل شيء يحدث في الحياه
هناك صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه والتي تعملون
على حشد دولي لتاييدها حدثنا عن صيغه
السلام الاوكرانيه ولماذا ترون فيها الحل
للوضع القائم ولانهاء الحرب وهل تناسب في
رايكم
الرسوم
لم تنشئ صيغه السلام من دون السبب لان
اوكرانيا سعد دائما من اجل السلام هناك
صيغه فاعله تقوم على كل الازمات التي
جلبتها هذه الحرب الحرب الروسيه التي
جلبتها الى اوكرانيا هذه ليست فقط نقاطا
واضحه جدا فيما يتعلق باحترام النظام
الاساسي للامم المتحده واحترام وحده اراضي
وسياده اوكرانيا ولكن ايضا لما جلبته
روسيا معها خطر نووي ويجب ان تجد الصيغه
حلها لا يمكن للعالم باسره اي خاطر بحياته
لمجرد ان روسيا استولت على اكبر محطه
للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا هناك ازمه بيئيه
نظرا لحقيقه ان روسيا فخخت مئات او حتى
الف الهكتارات من اراضينا ومناطق المياه
والمباني والمدارس ورياض الاطفال قاموا
بتلغيمها جميعا كم من الناس فقدوا اطرافهم
بالغين واطفال يجب ايضا تطوير هذا
البرنامج من قبل شركائنا الحرب ليست فقط
حول الاسلحه الحرب في المقام الاول هي
العواقب الناس فقدوا منازلهم ووالديهم
وهناك من فقد اطفاله تم خطف اطفال بالقوه
الى الاراضي الروسيه انت تعلم انه يوجد
بالفعل عشرات الالاف من الاطفال تم تسجيل
ذلك وتم اخذهم بالقوه وسرقتهم ونقلهم الى
اراضي الاتحاد الروسي
لن تفعل روسيا ذلك على الفور لكن هذه
الصيغه ليست لها هذه هي صيغه العالم روسيا
اليوم بلد حرب هي ليست مستعده بعد لهذه
الصيغه هذه هي صيغه السلام ونعرضها على كل
الدول لتتحد حول هذه الصيغه ونحن لا
نقترحها من دون السبب نحن في حال حرب ونرى
نتائج هذه الحرب من الازمات البيئيه الى
الخسائر البشريه وهي معادله عمليه للغايه
كل ما نقترحه وان تتوحد الدول حول تلك
النقاط التي تحترمها هذه الدوله او تلك
نحن لا نقول على سبيل المثال ان الدول
العربيه يجب ان تدعم جميع النقاط العشر
للصيغه هذه الصيغه هي عباره عن حرب مقسمه
الى عشره اجزاء وتحل كل مشكله على حده مع
الدول المعنيه والتي تكون جاهزه للحل
بالكامل لانها قضيه معقده اذا لم تقسم ليس
من السهل استيعابها
وقع الكثير من الضرر وهكذا على سبيل
المثال يمكن للدول العربيه ان تنظر الى ما
يناسبها واين تريد المشاركه على سبيل
المثال تبادل الاسرى اشياء مهمه عوده
الناس عوده الاطفال هذه مهمه تفاوضيه
ومطلوبه وهي في هذه الصيغه بعدها ياتي
الامن الغذائي نحن نفهم ان ممر البحر
الاسود الذي اغلقه الاتحاد الروسي اعتقد
ان الامن الغذائي يمثل التحديا للعالم كله
وبالتاكيد بنسبه الى القاره الافريقيه
ودون شكل العالم العربي بنسبه الى الكثير
من الدول الاسي هناك دول تفهم كيف يتم
بناء اليات العداله بالنسبه الى دفع
الاموال هناك المحاكم التي ستنظر في الاف
القضايا الجنائيه المرتكبه هذه الصيغه
عباره عن حبكه واقتراح ان هذه الدوله او
تلك تختار هذه النقطه او تلك لنفسها
ويتعاون العالم من اجل التحقيق السلام
عموما والسلام في القاره الاوروبيه خصوصا
يحتفل المسلمون عبر العالم ومنهم المسلمون
في اوكرانيا بعيد الفطر ما هي رسالتكم
بهذه المناسبه
العالم الاسلامي في هذا العيد اعتقد بصدق
ومن دون الاعتماد على الدين او اللغه او
اي اختلافات بيننا واتمنى ذلك لاوكرانيا
ولكم اتمنى ان يعم السلام المسلمين السلام
في الاسره واتمنى للجميع الصحه لانه قبل
حربنا كانت هناك حرب كبيره مع كوفيد وهي
ايضا موجه كبيره حصدت الكثير من الارواح
واتمنى لكم السلام والصحه بحيث تكون
العائله في المنزل دائما صاخبه ولكن ليس
من سماع طلقات ناريه بل من ضحك الاطفال
ويبدو لي ان هذا هو اهم شيء لانقاذ
عائلتنا وانقاذ منازلنا وحيث نرى احيانا
صراعا ان نفعل كل شيء حتى لا نجلبه ولكن
مع ذلك بصفه رئيس دوله في حال حرب اود ان
اتمنى للمسلمين في جميع انحاء العالم
فيكون دائما متحدين واقوياء هذا مهم جدا
شكرا جزيلا سيدي الرئيس اشكرك على وقتك
وعلى صراحتك
اشكرك جزيل الشكر
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام هذا اللقاء الخاص
مع الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيليسكي
تحدثنا فيه حول الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وتداعياتها على الصعيد العسكري والسياسي
والاقتصادي والانساني اشكركم على المتابعه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]